on a omis en fait la moitié de notre
flotte en service c'est à dire que nous
avons un gros volume de clients on sait
très bien que la peine au tribal de
l'activité nous avons mis la moitié nord
avec un service est dû qu aujourd'hui
nous avons quatre bateaux en service un
super pilote sur le beau sur la pointe
du goût et ainsi on se dit ah non ça n'a
donc ça nous permet de voir déjà comment
les comment ça se passe et voir comment
pourra continuer pour le moment en ce
qui concerne les horaires et bien sûr
avec la moitié des rotations seulement
maintenue on ne pourra pas avoir des
navettes à toutes les heures comme
d'habitude en d'habitude sur les trois
îles et un bateau du clae de mire donc
là on est passé à une union sur les
votations importantes c'est-à-dire les
premières rotations du matin les
premiers rotation un peu avant midi
jusqu'à midi en début d'après-midi en
fin de journée donc il ya un petit trou
entre entre 9h30 et à peu près 11 heures
et entre 14 heures et 16 heures à ce
moment